looks like we got two beards in the room
three if you can't your wife let's dive
in first question why such a couple I'm
kidding I'm totally I'm kidding that's
the second question I skipped ahead
let's get to the heart of the matter now
why can't you be like other actors good
ones speed round answer as quickly as
you can now if you had a gun to your
head
do you consider Deadpool the Green
Lantern of good movies
what's Eva Mendes like I don't know
what's Blake Lively like she's wonderful
now what's Blake Lively
like your pic right hey everybody we got
a whole bunch of Fox Marvel stuff going
on
Deadpool x-force there's a Kitty Pryde
movie that they just announced so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I cannot wait for them to start the
Deadpool 2 press tour
yeah well inside hey Jake
I think we're really all just waiting to
see how much Ryan Reynolds makes fun of
Avengers stuff in the interviews because
like this will be between both of the
Avengers film so Josh Brolin will be
back for Avengers 4 even though they've
already filmed all of his scenes for
that so Q all the purple man jokes but
thankfully the person who sort of the
Kevin Feige of Fox Marvel movies from an
executive standpoint said that
everything was going fine with Fox
Marvel Disney wasn't buying them to turn
them into Disney even the person who's
in charge of Legion was saying the same
thing about the TV shows they're not
buying all these characters to put
Disney eyes on them so Deadpool 3
x-force all the movies that they were
originally planning on making are still
getting made they haven't confirmed the
x-force roster but for the most part
it's being led by cable and Deadpool so
I'm assuming that negasonic is gonna
cross over Colossus will probably be in
it they'll add a couple more characters
there's been talk about including
psylocke there's been talk about x-23
but i still think that they want to keep
x-23 off in her own universe because of
the timeline stuff that they did with
the Logan movie and I don't think
any plans to recast Wolverine anytime
soon if they really do try to change
some of that Logan continuity in the
light of this Disney deal I would be
fine if they wanted to include x-23 in
the more mainstream films if they wanted
to bring her into the Deadpool universe
that would be hilarious but that's still
speculation at this point I think the
Deadpool movies have the best chance of
remaining unchanged just because the
tone of Deadpool is so different from
what's going on with the Avengers movies
in the MCU they'll probably just let him
be in his own little bubble by himself
we'll talk about crossover when we get
some more details the only thing that's
changed with the Deadpool movie in the
last couple of months is that TJ
Miller's gotten himself into a little
bit of trouble that same Kevin Feige
person said that they don't intend to
remove him from the movie because
they've already shot all of his scenes
the movie is pretty much done it's in
post-production right now if they don't
want to bring Wiesel back for x-force or
a Deadpool 3 it's the easiest thing in
the world for them to kill him off
screen and just have Deadpool make a
funny crayon drawing in some jokes about
oh this happened to weasel and that's
the end of it they never have to address
it again of all the characters in the
x-men universe Deadpool is the most
equipped for handling continuity errors
McAvoy or Stewart these timelines are so
confusing God you look like a house fire
was in another house fire wait you look
like a trash can full of [ __ ] was placed
on your shoulders and then you're in a
train fire that actually reminds me
Donald Glover was doing press over the
weekend and was talking about the
Deadpool TV series he made it sound like
they're almost done if not already done
writing it so we might wind up getting
to see some footage from that when they
get ready to drop the Deadpool movie I
think they just want to build on the
marketing and the awareness for Deadpool
when that happens during the summer to
launch the Deadpool TV series but they
haven't actually confirmed a premiere
date for that I think just because
animation takes so long like any time
you know that there's an animated series
coming and they don't tell you what the
date is it's because they don't know if
there's gonna be production delays but
when we get some more updates about that
I'll do more Deadpool TV videos and Tim
Miller you know former Deadpool director
is the person who is making the Kitty
Pryde movie now so for all of you shadow
cat bands we're finally gonna see a
really bad
kitty pryde movie in the most current
version of the comics right now she's
currently leading an x-men team in x-men
gold so she's the older version of the
character but the younger version is the
one that you talk about as Kitty Pryde
they gave her the shadow cat named
during the mid-80s when she was teaming
up with Wolverine like she's one of
those female characters that just works
really well with the Wolverine character
like Jubilee who interestingly enough
was brought in to replace Kitty Pryde on
the x-men when she joined the excalibur
team so if they really want to be
different from the x-men movies they
could do more Kitty Pryde Excalibur
stuff but then after that she came back
to the x-men team because she's just one
of the most popular x-men female
characters so that's why when they
started doing the new x-men gold run it
was meant to be super nostalgic so they
put a bunch of classic characters on the
team so that's why Kitty Pryde is the
new leader by the time they brought her
back to the x-men team Emma Frost had
become a thing so they used her to
balance that character out because Emma
Frost was like this hardcore cold his
ice [ __ ]
kitty was the mother like figure that
always cared about the students that
called Emma Frost on her [ __ ] so it
just depends on how old they want the
character to be if she's gonna be
younger or gonna be older whether or not
they're gonna call her shadow cat or
she'll be Kitty Pryde for the most part
she's been the adult version of her
character so usually the only time you
hear people calling her kitty
instead of shadow cat is the characters
that have known her for a long time like
Wolverine they didn't say anything about
Ellen Page coming back to play the
character again because she's still
pretty young but these are the three
different versions of Kitty Pryde that
we've seen so far in the movies physics
[Music]
see us there this might sting a little
they didn't say anything about how this
kitty pryde movies gonna connect to the
other films but remember they're making
Channing Tatum's gambit movie that will
also probably be loosely connected to
the x-men films but I think part of the
idea is to let it be its own thing so
they don't have to be shackled to the
tone of the mainstream x-men films but
until we hear more I would just expect
them to treat Kitty Pryde and gambit the
way they did the first debt poem movie
like hey this is an x-men film but it's
not really that connected there's just a
lot of x-men stuff happening inside of
it let me know in the comments what do
you think about the idea of them doing a
Kitty Pryde movie for those of you
asking about Super Bowl trailers yes
Deadpool 2 and New Mutants are both
coming up but the Fox people just said
no comment when people ask them about
Super Bowl trailers so we might not find
out about that for the next couple of
weeks but even if they don't drop a
Deadpool trailer we might see Ryan
Reynolds do some funny Deadpool promos
around the Superbowl because like Warner
Brothers DC films they don't spend a lot
of money on Super Bowl trailers but they
do try to use the Super Bowl to market
their stuff so Fox might do the same
thing just to save themselves the tens
of millions of dollars that it costs to
buy Super Bowl ads so we'll find out
about that pretty soon but while you
wait for everything click here for that
new black panther trailer and click here
for more Deadpool 2 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]